نحن الان انتقلنا من موقع الى موقع اخر في
نوردا النشاط السابقه كنا قرب مخيمات
الايواء او المخيمات التي انشاتها هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه افاد لايواء
سكان نورداغ والقرى المحيطه بها الان
انتقلت الى احد الاحياء الرئيسيه في
نورداغ كما تشاهدون هذا الحي بات كتلا من
الركام طبعا انتقلت الى هذا الحي بعد ان
انتهت اعمال
البحث والانقاذ عن ناجين ستبدا قريبا خلال
ايام عمليات ازاله هذه الانقاض حي كامل
دمر وبات اكواما من الركام والكتل
الخرسانيه والابنيه التي في الخلف ايضا هي
ابنيه غير صالحه للسكن طبعا مع الاسف يعني
نشاهد حجم الضرر الكبير هنا انتقلت الى
هذا الحي للحديث عن احصائيات رسميه بدات
تظهر مؤخرا خلال الساعات الماضيه
كالتصريح الرئيس التركي اكتمال العمل مع
15 عشره الف مبنى مدمر من اصل 19000 مبنى
مدمر اي بقاء 4000 مبنى ما زالت هناك
محاولات للوصول لوصول او محاولات فرق
الانقاذ مستمره في تلك المباني في
الولايات العشر المتضرره طبعا تم تصنيف
يعني نتحدث الان في الارقام الرسميه تم
تصنيف
47,000 بناء تضم اكثر من 200 الف بيت او
وحده سكنيه كمنازل منهاره او منازل بحاجه
الى هدم عاجل او منازل تعرضت لاضرار بليغه
بالتالي نتحدث ان
حجم الاضرار في المباني ما بين المباني
منهاره او متصدعه او متشققه وفيها اضرار
كثيره بلغ 47,000 بناء في الولايات العشر
الكبرى طبعا هذا يعني ان هذه المباني
بالكامل غير صالحه للسكن حتى
التي لم تنهار هي غير صالحه هذا يعني ان
هناك حاجه لبناء 47 الف بناء جديد ليستوعب
اكثر من 200 او يضم اكثر من 200 الف شقه
سكنيه والرئيس التركي وما امس تحدث عن بدء
حكومه الحكومه التركيه او استعداد الحكومه
التركيه لبناء اكثر من 30 الف وحده سكنيه
ابتداء من مارس القادم